La plus mystérieuse des pyramides d'Égypte.
Le tombeau de Snéfrou, Le père de Khéops,
105 mètres de haut.
Strictement fermé au public.
Il est très rare de pouvoir y pénétrer.
Même pour un égyptologue,
Vassil n'a pu l'explorer que 4 fois
depuis le début de sa carrière.
Pour lui, toutes les autres pyramides
n'ont fait que copier les principes
qui ont été inventés ici, il y a 4700 ans.
- Ça, c'est le couloir que descend vers les
entrailles de la pyramide,
vers la première chambre.
Et là, on a 70 mètres, et on doit se pencher.
Parce que c'est à peine un mètre
sur un mètre pratiquement.
Et donc, quelque part,
quand on rentre vers le tombeau du pharaon,
on doit se plier.
- On va utiliser l'encoche.
Pour accéder au cœur de la pyramide.
Il faut franchir de nombreux obstacles.
- Oui, il y a toujours des chauves souris.
Vassil progresse par une série de galeries de
plus en plus étroites.
- Ça tape les chauves souris !
Là, ça monte tout droit.
Une architecture complexe, dont personne n'a
jamais vraiment compris la logique.
- À quoi ça sert ? Je ne sais pas.
Ça va du haut, et ça descend,
je ne sais pas où.
Il y a encore, peut-être,
une autre chambre à trouver.
Après une demi-heure d'exploration,
Vassil parvient enfin
dans ce qui fut autrefois la
chambre funéraire du pharaon.
Une chambre mystère, car contrairement
aux autres pyramides d'Égypte,
elle était, à sa découverte,
totalement vide.
- Il devrait y avoir un sarcophage,
mais on ne l'a pas.
On n'a jamais trouvé sarcophage de Snéfrou.
Les pyramides fonctionnaient comme des
machines à résurrection.
Le roi renaissait dans son tombeau,
puis montait vers le ciel
par ce long couloir,
toujours dirigé vers le nord.
C'est sans doute par là,
dans l'antiquité,
que les pilleurs se sont glissés pour
s'emparer des objets de valeur du pharaon.
- Cette règle pour les pyramides,
est aussi leur faiblesse,
parce que les voleurs, par la suite,
savaient parfaitement que
pour entrer dans une pyramide,
il faut aller au centre de la face,
au milieu de la face nord, et chercher
le coureur qui descend dans la pyramide.
C'est pour ça que les rois suivants
ont commencé à mettre des faux couloirs,
à l'est, au sud, à l'ouest,
pour tromper les voleurs.
Malgré leur ingéniosité,
les pharaons ont rarement réussi
à mettre leurs trésors
à l'abri des voleurs.
Toutânkhamon est le seul
à y être parvenu.
La capitale des pharaons, Memphis,
était située ici,
à l'emplacement de cette vaste palmeraie.
Aujourd'hui, il n'en reste presque rien.
Quant à Saqqarah, sans doute le site
le plus sacré de l'histoire du pays.
Il se trouvait juste en face, en surplomb,
sur une pente de désert,
où furent bâties les premières
pyramides d'Égypte.